foreign
[Music]
what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation it is time to start the
boys spin-off Jen V John how are you I
am very excited for this spin-off cert
that'll get better Corey how are you
effervescently ready for Generation V
that's right man you're a huge boys fan
over
an 06 from the beginning of the end
cannot wait to see what they do with the
shared Universe of boys you know what I
can't wait to see what our audience does
when they check out
www.rejacknationshop.com right now John
and I are rocking these shirts who
influences the influencers but we also
got this shirt we just launched this
shirt snip snip Ahsoka baby get it and
this one we have and that one and that
one and we've got even more and it is
seriously one of the best ways to
support the channel and this month
already has been our most successful
month so thank you guys so much your
support means a lot and especially when
it comes to a show like this which
undoubtedly we're probably gonna get a
yellow dollar bill sign the sub Port is
very much appreciated with that in mind
leave a like on this video go ahead
subscribe click the notification Bell
because of course we're going to cover
the rest of genvey and as always
following three action watch along where
you single with your copy of GMB
available for super sexual Rejects at
our patreon page to cover some things
exclusively over there with reactional
Heights and Watch Dogs included let's
swing into action
foreign
s rip up the history books because in
New York this morning godolcan
University All-Star eight straight a
train
first African-American on the world's
Premier super team black panther welcome
a train oh which proves what we have
been saying for a long time we live in a
post-racism world
there it is this is history don't smile
I'm not you have to do it like Kendall
he goes clubbing with Jake Paul and
Scott Disick
delete it
[Music]
power power let me get you some Pepto
yeah it really is fine yeah I should
give like birth to Super beings
I'm so comfortable right now I'm so
terrified of how this debuts this is a
room I belong in
I'm fine oh wow
oh my god oh jeez
[Music]
oh no did it just yeah oh no you know it
did
oh girl
oh no
God oh no
oh
[Music]
Iceman and Carrie that's already such a
moment for a teenage girl yeah they just
made it better she won't forget
couldn't even have five minutes of
Sweetness in this world
I'm a bad [__] and I got bad anxiety
ever since Starlight left the seven I've
just been inspired to speak my own truth
with all the boundaries right and that's
just me being real okay so this is the
timeline before and now it's present to
the boys after boy season three okay
her story
this guy the only author in this
universe that's cool she has blood
bending Powers what everyone wants blood
bending I'll take it that's a Legend of
Korra reference for y'all well Avatar
oh that's always the Palm it's all fake
YouTube
naked beautiful
I just realized I didn't even see the
trailer for this
she's like a Morlock but how fast does
she regenerate blood yeah she gonna
blackout does she need to be eating red
meat always
oh yeah that's oof oh wow
it's like an old school Wolverine power
like it hurts every time yeah
oh
no
she's gonna come back later
Ah that's a call back we've seen that
video before
[Music]
wow
just fries right I mean it's a full ride
wouldn't be surprised if you ended up
protecting a city one day I think you
meant to say first black woman in the
seven that's exactly what I hope for you
but a god you graduate you could wipe
all that clean and start fresh so don't
[__] it up
God you
the center she's at did they explore
that and the boys diabolical I'm Dean
Indira Shetty welcome to godalkin
University see the woman from Game of
Thrones I think so curriculum such as
hero ethics and understanding branding
the Beast guy
alumni include stars from such shows as
Riverdale Pretty Little Liars yes
it's like a church of the seven
greatest cities wow oh the Hogwarts
combo with odds magic good oldkin is a
safe space for you to thrive
you're a villain ranked one do that as
sinisterly as possible please so it's
like Xavier's School meets Catholic
School meets Hogwarts meets My Hero
Academia Starship Troopers what else
I love that the Vaught branding is so
strong but also like separately the
seven branding because the comics always
felt like the world was so established
and this will build out the boys World
by having a show running simultaneously
autographed Maeve merch is it the same
day when I got you whoa so I figured
whoa is she really tiny against the
toughest [__] here
yes
my gerbil David cruso yes it's about to
go down welcome to fight night uh that
dribble Cannon
[Music]
oh this really does feel like a college
show I think it's delighting something
about like the way it's shot right just
the vibe in the music choices not the
casting and the setting
the show the literal commercial for a
college
are you cool with David cruso I've never
had a pet who's David Caruso you didn't
see Jade who references Jade
so what were you doing
um a YouTube show
Fun Size with a little Cricket well I'm
kind of like PewDiePie without the Nazi
stuff wowie good
so what are we doing here exactly dude
his workouts are practically the social
event of the season
what's up Golden Boy oh yeah you know
when Golden Boy flames on his clothes
burn off Andy's uncut oh he doesn't have
a suit that actually accompanies his
power set not yet I think it's
intentional for him I'm not sweating duh
incredible Steve or anyone that has the
in their name I got 10 grand on damn
I'm sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
what is the other guy's power so you
just didn't vote
let's say we're opening on a gladiator
match
they finally sea cucumber
hi Kevin I'm gonna be down there one day
[Applause]
please tell me he heals
does he like the detachable kid it's
like a violent version of detachable kid
yeah all right next time thanks man yeah
oh sportsmanship can I borrow your phone
I don't have one yet you don't have a
phone yet wait are you Amish
blemish
coming to ABC this fall Jordan Lee first
of all you're awesome I signed up for
Brinks freshman intro to crime fighting
but it's not on my schedule what's your
name Marie Moreau you were rejected it's
called alliteration
Superior name everyone who majors in
crime fighting takes intro when you're
competing with kids who have cleared
homicide cases who have over a million
followers and you bug
ger you don't even have an insta social
media factors into this no I made the
call on his ta who are you to reject me
Jordan
whoa
God damn it's the fastest throw I've
ever seen they're gonna need to buy me a
new shirt professor
sir she I mean he they rejected me from
your intro class they don't know me is
that so it's Clancy we're not a bad guy
I mean inevitably please no I love them
I could go all the way I just I just
need the chance come on old white man
performing arts is a fine program you'd
be on Dancing With the Stars ugh I loved
it just like the boys it's you don't
know which way cliche is gonna go like
does that work and get her in or is it
because that show always like skirts
expectations very true very true
oh she's got to do something to go viral
oh yeah I could call oh jeez we got a
runner
it's stunts what's going on it's
tweaking on meth oh just regular meth
just get old-fashioned meth plus server
Powers equals
yes
[Music]
leave such a trail it's like scorpion
it's not meth I'm not going back to the
[__] Woods
stay out of the Forbidden Forest it is
Hogwarts
I did not think we'd be following him
yeah I thought it would stay a mystery
for a bit what is the woods now we know
Darkness lurks in this world
oh the woods Performing Arts won't be so
bad just trying to make friends like a
normal human what's wrong Performing
Arts it's for all the most annoying
people go
[Laughter]
an elevated superhero Thing Really a
meditation on Grief told through 70
years of sitcoms and Zach Braff is
directing we're friends so see yes the
most annoying people
theater kids I've seen you in something
I did do a small reoccurring in Chicago
Fire hey real her YouTube channel Little
Cricket oh my God you are so funny holy
[__] no that's right
um fun size a little Cricket oh this is
what it's like when I meet actors I
respect who happen to know me
fun sizes Greg
and where have I seen you
right here
[Music]
oh it's that fire girl from season three
Soldier Boys X you remember when we
first met chapter nine of your book I
had to sit on a folding chair in your
folks living room because you kept
burning holes in the front Arnold kid
Patrick yeah
name carbide alloy oh concept art
yeah no more showing your balls to
America hoping AI didn't make that what
a great thing to do between seasons of
like impact and but you my boy are going
to the seven no draft no nothing the
next white guy in the seven it is
interesting to step back into a world
where they have no awareness of how
corrupt and evil the seven actually is
yeah yeah there's an element of tragedy
baked in I was coming up with your
superhero name you wanna hear it
bloody Marie oh that's terrible it's
kind of nice a skinny kid you seen them
before the way they dragged them off
what about this bloodline that's right
he was out of control okay coagula
that's a great one a few of us are going
on a field trip off campus Golden Boy
myself a few others you should come
let's go Madame plasma
breaking curfew I can't afford the
trouble I'm fighting building at 10. if
you change your mind you need to learn
to take risks you don't understand the
world ending trouble I'll be in if I'm
busted my dad is really strict I'm gonna
be talking off about this the whole
night so if you don't
have anything to wear please borrow
whatever you want from my closet
I like their chemistry together
damn girl glow up I'm Luke
I Know Who You Are
never
ran it in
come on we'll take my car
not the same stuff the other guy was on
I hope they know how to sneak out yeah
it's the gold Porsche subtle
oh no
she's on YouTube
let's go get some validation you deserve
it I can't believe I'm at seven Tower
let me guess you were six years old in a
mave costume just dreaming about making
this now I do
I didn't even know I had
12. my parents gave me v as a baby but
it didn't hit till puberty oh they must
have been excited
no idea
I'm sorry uh I'm lying what
my parents died I don't know why I do
that my brother passed away too I'm
sorry but was it similar to or did you
just die he just got sick for my sister
I wanna prove to her that I'm not being
a hero is uh it's not what you think you
know if you're gonna do this make sure
you do it for you
because I'm not don't do it for people
they cast so well everybody's so
interesting and so quickly
wowie and you stopped at 14. yeah can
you try something yeah you knew it was
coming Pete I don't want you to think
I'm weird shriek down girly supposed to
be with the guys I always ask for at
least date two
but I wouldn't really work because like
Anatomy
he wants her to be the gerbil
this could be fun at it
[Music]
[Laughter]
I feel it
whoa like the Tom Cruise memes do not
turn her into a Kinks or fetishize her
existence
what do our two League girls put up such
a front yeah who in life does that it's
not real
oh
yes good no take off she's not taking
off she's going right back in there
oh
oh my
whoa
so she retains the strength she's is
another size down
how do these powers develop with these
specific triggers
okay
[Music]
oh my goodness you've ever seen
no I mean yeah relatively ugh
what this must have been like to shoot
actually give us a whole close-up on it
and the pilot a macro that
responsibility and having to work with
my dad [__] that that's all you oh no
and I'm proud of you I love you man what
secret are you harboring what happened
to your brother did you kill him yeah
who's that guy's dad oh [__] someone's
rolling don't you think
yeah definitely oh
what's gonna make her bleed oh God I'm
so afraid
[Music]
the woods
into the woods to look for trauma
[Laughter]
so he was experimented on too huh I
wonder if that skinny guy's brother it's
a good theory maybe he has to take the
power from his brother or something I'm
waiting for my boyfriend fair enough
elbow heads I stay Tales I leave are we
dead
[Music]
that all the bird can do yes
if I can get this little birdie into his
cup who you agreed to I'd best go home
with me and at worst we hit the dance
floor and have a good time
oh I feel like people would notice that
right yep
[Music]
man
more Powers is too risky ever we need to
get the [__] out of here now
come on uh oh you guys are perfect for
this episode
yeah oh she's noticing they're not doing
anything heroic come on she's gonna be
the one caught saving hers like saving
your mom go for it
[Music]
that sound sounds great
bloodbend
fall
oh you're gonna go viral oh for heroics
she's alive you could be A Healer on the
seventh you're living everyone's dream
and your roommate's gonna resent you for
going viral too yeah but you're also out
this lady they're gonna let it slide
the girl hero
okay in the chair sorry for all the
blood on your clothes oh God worth it oh
she's sweet I know so many people like
Marie right Professor Brinks office
called he wants to see you oh it's
happening just me also I'm not your
assistant get a [__] phone
I've dedicated my life to studying
superheroes I think it's safe to say
that I know more about soups than just
about any Soul alive which might be too
good Fred McAllister of Scarborough UK
who's that some powerless schmuck
see his old dog Arnold jumped into the
ocean and he started to go Wonder so
Fred he hopped into the drink and he
managed to save his old mutt but can
drowned in the process that's sad that
being a hero a real hero is not about
Glory it's about sacrifice
that's serving and protecting there's a
way to manipulate in that way of
thinking isn't there not this guy never
sorry I'm to tell you this but you're
being expelled there it is I was worried
when it was positively brought in Jordan
they're going all the way they could
save thousands of people but not if TMZ
finds out that they almost let a woman
bleed to death because they were high
somebody's got to take that hit wow dude
I can't go back
send me to this this adult facility that
you're resourceful girl you'll figure
something out
man whose blood powers are yours they're
a non-starter in Middle America there's
no four quadrant appeal
wow if it's either she's gonna think
she's getting expelled and then no it's
good but when it was good when it was
good I was like just kidding yeah I knew
I shouldn't have gone what happened I
didn't ask for this for you oh leave me
alone but but we're coming of age
absolutely
it's not a dream dream it's real damn
please help me he's in the upside down
[Music]
it's also a tricky power because you
leave your DNA everywhere
it's very findable how you feel because
I'm sweating cocaine
[Laughter]
y'all are the best
oh you're about to see something you're
not supposed to yeah what about me in
that room
oh no oh that's what I'm talking about
you don't know about the woods
okay please he fell asleep with a camel
lit in his mouth he burned himself how
would you heard the guy say in the woods
you have to come oh no man come on damn
it dude move
not until you chill out
[Music]
and honest you got what do you got
cool
they have different powers in the
different forms
speed maybe
they're both Wonder Twins
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh geez
oh
you're going down homelander junior
there's no need to kill them
I made my point should we do this later
it's Gotta Be protocols in the school
for violence cut right to the homelander
Statue that's a journey of where he
could be headed
he killed Brink
[Music]
hey hey take it easy
you know [__] everyone else it's just me
and you you know I love you hmm
I've been like this
oh that's tragic was he gonna I love you
please don't burn me
I think he's gonna dispose of himself
yeah I wonder if it's is he gonna
self-immolate
wow
flavon's gonna do right now oh
yep yep yep yep
that's a good show
wow too
oh man all right well we got two more
episodes so out so we just want to make
these discussions short
um but uh part of me was skeptical about
I didn't even watch the trailer for this
part of me was skeptical about this show
that it would just be something
capitalizing on the boys and could be
just be
discount boys but it's something very
different and the writing and quality
and acting is just as good yeah it's
well deserves to be a like a companion
piece to the boys this is really really
really great stuff yeah I
I love for a first episode I love that a
lot that was that was excellent I'm I'm
very much interested in uh I mean
obviously you know the boys has the
freshness of an introduction of a new
world and whatever but I love the kind
of characters we're choosing to focus on
and sure we got a mystery that is I'm
looking forward to unraveling it but the
way they toy around with like certain
cliches and directions you think it'll
go they know how to mislead and
misdirect uh really well done but I'm
very much invested in our main Central
character
uh God that was uh that was really well
done guys
all right everyone let's move on
managers
got his opinions in and uh you guys are
here just a little bit let us know in
the comments what you think of Greg's
video do you agree with Greg you
disagree with Greg let us know thumbs up
for Greg
um Juan say something deep oh hey well I
mean yeah this is a day and age wherein
I almost always now greet any sort of
spin-off or expansion of successful you
know franchise core with a bit of
skepticism just because there are so
many things that feel like watered down
you know tributes to the thing we all
love but I think this is a really
wonderfully pitched show so far in that
you know the boys is looking at all this
from inside the machine and from an eye
line that is you know more at eye level
with the machine whereas this gives you
an opportunity to explore a world like
this with the implications it has from
the shadow beneath the machine and I
think that's a really cool thing and
then you know everything else I think
you know the characters they've laid out
here are interesting and appealing the
acting is great and this just went
places in a first episode I wasn't
expecting it took me by surprise just as
much as there are moments where you're
like sitting there going okay well if
this is going to be positive reception
or negative reception it's going to go
the opposite way you know there are
things beyond that where I was like wow
I was not expecting them to go as hard
or for certain things to play out this
way and now you know it's like there's
that whole new sense of Discovery from
episode two of like who who's Really
Gonna Be The Ensemble of this thing
aside from you know our main character
and Marie and I assume Cricket is going
to come back in some way yeah um but
yeah no this was a really striking
action looks good you know for the most
part there were a couple action moments
where I was like okay this is a bit like
a TV editing fight but for the most part
when that's the boys you sure but uh but
when it counts and when they do their
big crazies spectacular moments those
always hit and yeah the power is very
striking all that good stuff main girl
kind of reminds me a bit of a placement
of Starlight where she's in a journey of
discovering just uh how much
disillusionment there is in the universe
she wishes to live in but it's also like
a form of escapism yeah for her to hide
from her from her pain you know but it I
I think you could draw a lot of peril
it's interesting how when you look at
the boys season one the first super that
we followed was Starlight yeah a long
smear but then you know of course you're
following Huey's Journey but following
Starlight where both were like oh I want
to be part of the seven and I have this
certain certain sort of vision of what
it means to be a superhero and they both
seem like their purpose is to be part of
the seven that that is what what will
Define them and make them their greatest
self uh where but their backgrounds are
very different you know hers is a bit
like Rogue yeah yeah
from X-Men 2000 uh yes Anna pack when
the only road that they only wrote that
effort is the Last Stand take it away
koi monologue okay a few different
things hit me immediately one I actually
came from the other perspective I didn't
watch the trailer but because I didn't
want to know the tone because I trust in
Kripke and Goldberg and what they've
done so far with the boys I didn't even
know that they developed it oh really I
thought there was like a whole new oh I
followed the trades like hard on this
yeah so I I avoided footage but for the
opposite reason
um I'm a bit inundated with this
spin-off culture and like the obviously
the barrage of superhero content I like
most of it I like a little over half of
it but I like a lot of it and I think
overall it's hard when there's so much
of it to find fresh ways but I thought
if anyone could make a spin-off it'd be
the boys team so since I knew I think I
was more optimistic but I likewise
avoided it because I knew that I trusted
them to do what I thought they would and
this is actually exceeding that
expectation because the boys to me was
the exact right time to make a show that
played with what the comics were doing
back in 06 which was that was when team
books were really popular that was when
it was like the crash of the 90s led to
this big surge of new comics in the
early 2000s like the Ultimate Universe
and that led to a lot of big team books
being commentaries on the team worlds of
DC and Marvel right you had like the
authority we're gonna get soon and you
had all these like almost superhero
superhero teams so the boys was really
jarring and that it was like okay how do
we do a commentary in a new way and it
was like let's just see how far we can
go and it was just hit the homers of of
violence and depravity and it was really
swinging for those fences so I think
what they did really well with the boys
was it came out at the exact right time
of okay we have established superheroes
are popular and how do you do a
commentary on popularity and subvert
those expectations without seeming like
you're just doing what everyone else is
doing with parody and I think the boys
did it by addressing uh capitalism by
addressing basically the Amazon of it
all with vot by addressing the political
nature of homelander by doing all those
things and I was like how do you do that
with a spin-off culture and I think what
I find most interesting about this show
is with the boys there's this whole nest
of world where you meet a barrage of
characters per issue some issues feel
like they're uh Justice League sometimes
it feels like specifically Batman and
Robin sometimes it feels like this and I
was hoping the show would capture the
feeling of you immediately have to be
endeared to these characters you immely
have to care about their powers you
immediately have to feel like what
they're a commentary on and I was
worried we would be wanting just the
seven so what they did here genius to me
is they make sure the seven is this
overarching paranoia and like drama
saying the inside the the system the
machine and then from the outside but
they're making it from a younger
perspective so you're looking up at the
thing that we were commenting on looking
up at the thing the first season but
whereas I find the boys is a great
commentary on a lot of a little bit more
right-leaning ideas and that that that
commentary of power and Fascism and
those things this is a commentary on
what youth culture sees as this
Progressive Movement as being overly
Progressive for the sake of pain
entering and in the first episode
they're acknowledging a lot of the
things a lot of these companies are
doing to like look how good we're doing
and acknowledging so this is kind of
going at the other angle from like that
one's taking Jabs the right and left
some this one's taking the Jabs at the
left and the right sum but it's coming
from a younger looking up perspective
versus The Authority looking down all
while tying in the world and making it a
more immersive world so I think not only
is this a great way to build out the
world of the boys I've mentioned a few
times in the episode it's a really great
like between Seasons World building but
it doesn't feel like you have to watch
the boys because it's got this
overarching young different flavor so
this is the way to do a spin-off because
it could be its own thing and I'm so
immersed well I think especially with uh
I'm not really familiar with Craig
Rosenberg but knowing some of Eric
kripke's work you know and Evan
Goldberg's work something that I think
they can both really capture very well
especially Evan Goldberg's uh prior work
as a producer or writer is you mentioned
Youth and this really captures the you
know college adolescence of it all and
that
socializing feelings again there's like
there's qualities to it that
that that peer pressure that shyness
that coming out of the shell forming
your own identity finding your
confidence amongst others it's like
they're they're elements of our main
character that remind me of both
Starlight and Huey from season one yeah
kind of like mix into one and putting
them in a collagen virus which is so
approachable because like that's the
character you want to have the eye line
for yeah yeah and I like this
sympathetic approach that they had with
the person who's like oh are they going
to be the big super bat but they're not
they're really just someone who has been
wrong in some way it also is why
miscalculated decisions that was cool
the boys does that thing and I mentioned
it like twice in this but the boys is
always so good at being like you
expected and even once your three
seasons in you think they can't keep
doing that and this pilot had more
surprises than I expected and this pilot
by itself feels like a more of a I I
haven't seen a pilot feel this much like
its own like okay now I'm invested so
quickly well you know I think that there
is a lot more I think I think you know
when boys premiered there was a a lot
more I call it
um more guile to the way it was done
where here
it's just
more character storytelling I think you
know what I mean where I think boy is
part of the appeal of it when it first
debuted was the commentary yeah you know
how clearly it's bouncing right off of
what you just saw at the multi yeah that
was so clever yeah but it's still
character driven us invested um we're
here that's like no we already know the
world that are inhabiting and the
commentary feels very secondary as
opposed to the character Journey like
the way they capture the how haunted our
main character which I feel too do you
know her name's Marie thank you go
what's going on John another name uh
Marine Moreau Marie Moreau yeah I like
the island of Dr Morris clever yeah
um the way they capture Marie and how
haunted she is by her past
I I think always the way they play with
the sound design the mixture of that man
that was cool throws you into the
nightmare of how that she's always
trying to escape now she's always
putting up a front complimented by the
the co-leading girl the the YouTube
personality Cricket she feels very
relatable for is because I've just met
so many living in L.A you meet a lot of
people like that where they have that
certain type of bubbly
um extroverted personality you're
clearly depressed
you can see it no and I I thought that
she was really well fleshed out
um as well but yeah no it it com it's
commenting on like influencer culture oh
my God so and that's the the youth
looking up but it feels authentic they
didn't have to say sus like they I
actually acted yeah yeah
can I say the d word at the end DIC is
that allowed I don't know YouTube just
spell it out okay so I'm also impressed
one of the things the boys comment does
so well is it's it's really gonna try to
you or we can keep in mind
I'll say the D in the comics the D is
used very humorously and I really was
impressed at the amount of D used for
jokes here and how it worked like these
are these are funny and this is like
that's the type of humor the boys
captures but it was able to do it as a
commentary it didn't feel like it was
overdone great use of D yeah yeah it's
funny you're tragic as it should be yeah
man this was this was really this is
this was really cool I really like this
a lot let's watch the second episode
all right guys what did you think about
it leave your thoughts down below be
sure to leave a like subscribe thank you
to all I've been checking out some real
rejects apparel we will catch you all on
the flippity flip which is the very next
episode see you guys
[Music]